JOSH ANDERSON OUT THERE AS WELL
CANADIENS ALMOST DID LIKEWISE.
>> Craig: WATCH THEHE
NEWCOMER DAVID SAVARD.
WHO WAS ON THE CAULFIELD WITH
TYLER TOFFOLI.
[WHISTLE]
>> Chris: THAT STICKS TO
CAMP
GAINED A LOT OF THE START.
YOU COULD GET A SENSE FROM BOTH
TEAMS.
AND BOTH COACHES SAYING THE
PLAYERS ARE
CENTERING PASS HOPPED OVER THE
STICK AND CANADIENS HAVE BEENEN
>> Craig: YOU MENTIONED THE
FRONT.
BLOCKED THERE BY PETRY AND AWAY
GOES EVANS WITH AN OUTLET FOR
ARMIA. SIX.
CAME STORMING BACK TO TIE.
BUT THOSE OVERTIME GOALS WERE
THE DIFFERENCE MAKERS. NYLANDER.
TAVARES..
HIS CENTERING PASS.
RITCHIE A OF THE GUYS
SHELDON KEEFE SAID YOU HAVE TO
PLAY BET INCREDIBLY UNHEARD OF.
BE A
HERE'S DERMOTT PLAYING IT BACK
>> Craig: I LIKE THIS FOR
AND DID A GOOD JOB TRYING TO
GOING TO HAVE TO IMPROVE SOT OF.
AND HE SAID IT'S
>> Chris: IN BEHIND THE NET FOR
FRONT BUT EVANS AS WELL.
GOOD CLEAR BY CHIAROT GOES AFTER
DERMOTT.
KNOCKS HIM
HERE'S KERFOOT GOOD POKE-CHECK
THERE BY KULAK.
HE
AIR. RITCHIE IN FRONT.
THAT'S KNOCKED OFF THE STICK OF.
BANK PASS AND STAND UP AT THE
LINE WITH KULAK. HE'S HAD SO
FAR --OFF.
NYLANDER JUMPS ON.
GETS LEFT TO THE OUTSIDE.
IT GOES TO GALLAGHER.
WATCHED BY ENGVALL. REACT
WITH THOSE>> Chris: GALLAGHER T
AT MUZZIN.
AND MUZZIN GOT THE LICENSE
A S
LATE.
WE SEENN